[Applause]
near attend and what should the
Democrats be being doing be doing I
guess be doing to attract disaffected
Republicans who are fleeing the GOP are
we catching them in the net you know I
my view of this is that you're right
that the country is facing an
existential threat right now and we have
to make alliances wherever and so I
think we should welcome them I think we
have to recognize that accountability is
only gonna count Trump voter right yeah
yeah
we're friends yeah yeah you gotta talk
to each other
we can't you gotta share this country we
got to start talking and making inroads
we can't just take and welcome them with
open arms okay let's say black night ask
Koli on is there anything that could
happen that would make you say okay we
need stricter common sense gun laws
since you think because it's it's
amazing to me how everything always goes
to we need stricter gun laws in response
to everything with respect to firearms I
think there needs to be a more holistic
look and approach to it because if we
take into account the way things were
before we have more gun laws now than we
did before but yet supposedly we're
still doing because we did get rid of
the assault weapons ban there are state
there are states that have actually
deregulated gun laws over the last 10 15
years you say 20 to 30 years ago we have
less you know I'd say in the 1990s we
didn't we had an assault weapons ban and
that was actually not ended and that was
important in the south they've passed a
bunch of things to undo restrictions on
gun like stand your ground like stand
your ground that's you know danger well
why wouldn't he yeah well for one reason
I mean the statistics on black people
standing their ground against white
people versus the reverse and does not
come out well for black people ya know
so for my right
so I should I should forfeit my right
dog no no that specific law stand your
ground if I'm scared I get to shoot you
is the way I interpret Stan you're great
and that's really how it's the police
and when it's a white person shooting a
black person that that is forgiving a
lot more than the reverse if that is the
case right and then that's predicated on
race right and things a disproportionate
effective Stand Your Ground law right
then of course that's a criminal justice
issue right um then yeah something needs
to be done about that but the idea that
if somebody is threatening my life I
shouldn't have to be forced to retreat
to a wall before I decide to defend my
life if they're threatening it No yeah I
mean but that's just always been a lot I
mean people have loosened standard Ranas
change this so you're not inherently
against the idea of concept of stand
your ground you just against the way
it's been plucked no I think stand your
ground is a is is basically makes it so
that it's easier to kill somebody and I
objected that
you know we had a rule which is what
your life has to be the normal rule
before standard ran was that your life
had to be threatened and with stand your
ground it's like anything that you
perceive as a threat that's the best
part that's a slippery slope again then
that's predicated on a subjective
standard right what would that not be
the standard is inherently subjective in
a self-defense
well because my understanding of stand
your ground from an objective standard
is I have to be I'm not forced to have
my back against the wall if my life is
threatened to defend my life I'm
standing my ground here Michael Pollan
do you see a future where the government
sponsors care for mental health what
would it take to get there well we have
a real mental health crisis in this
country one of the reasons people are
interested in psychedelic that is very
involved with the gun crisis I mean that
yes we often yeah it's a debate is it
the guns or is it an offense well you
have the suicide rate is up what 20
percent in the last few years
depression is up 18 percent since 2005
addiction is rampant and and mental
healthcare in this country has very few
tools it's really broken if you compare
mental health care to any other branch
of medicine oncology cardiology
infectious disease they've all
accomplished important things they've
reduce suffering they prolong lifespan
you can't say that mental health that's
not true come on I mean a hundred years
ago the Kennedys were lobotomizing their
daughter because that's how they do that
hundred years ago I mean it was a long
time ago 100 years ago I think he means
over the last I mean over the last few
decades right but but haven't they come
up with things that I depressants help
son I remember even something like Mike
Wallace talking about they didn't have
antidepressants when he was today then
there were a few do baby definitely
pointless you know just pour something
in the test tube and make it better
right well it's not that easy but they
didn't have that option at all now 50
years but the antidepressants we have
actually many people don't like taking
them though their effectiveness fades
over time they're very hard to get off
so the cost suicide and they cause
suicide yes
yet if there's a suicide blamed on LSD
that's a huge story right but it's kind
of routine this is say that our problems
are not a constant I'm not a Luddite
when I say this but I think the
technology has completely upended mental
health in this country and we're gonna
we all love uber we want to order a car
I'm gonna go to OpenTable and and get a
dinner reservation but so many of our
kids are now shut-ins devoid of personal
interaction and instead creating
identities that just don't match that's
at the root of depression addiction
obsession all these own damn phones well
this is live on the actually that's
another addiction that's another form
terrible addiction yes okay I don't
think she created suicide rates have
increased amongst older men rural
communities people I mean we it's not
universal this is the gun problem a
majority of gun deaths in the u.s. are
suicide in the and the research is much
clearer on gun control and and gun gun
ownership rates and suicide than with
homicide it's you know the the crime
rate effects were unclear the suicide
rate effects are very clear if there are
fewer guns out there people attempt
suicide as much but they don't succeed
as often because it's absolutely not
that's if there was a direct correlation
between the number of guns that were
available and suicides we would be
leading the world in suicide there are
also cultural fewer fewer suicides among
black and Hispanic people than among
white and Asian people independent of
gun ownership so we have demographic
advantages we should have an even bigger
advantage over other advanced countries
and suicide rates than we do and also we
do have most guns but they're there in
the hands of fewer people in other words
the people who like guns have many guns
there was a guy last week Nicole with
five hundred and fifty three guns if
that picture that this guy's arsenal oh
my god this is what they found in this
guy's house come on
[Laughter]
we have to understand something right so
I get it right you're not a gun person
worried a better person like that
basically killing a lot of having the
ability easily a lot the only flattered
by one person children to reflect the
tribunes you're attributing a priority
you're inherently attributing a negative
character to firearms outright right
there at fire right but you're not
advocating banning cars or limiting
people's access to two vehicles you
can't take what I mean the number of
people who are murdered by guns is much
higher than the people murdered by cars
[Applause]
yeah intentional murder isn't horrible
though for someone to die in a car
accident versus somebody don't really
say why this is why we're never no
disrespect to either of you we're never
gonna get anywhere on this issue the
best we can hope for is a better
integration of data because I'm sick and
tired of reading in the newspaper the
following day well there was this
warning sign and this agency knew this
and this knew this right left hand of
the right hand was just not good
I don't agree with that at all but the
but also the one the last point I want
to make with respect to the using the
number of guns out there and you feeling
some type of way is I look at guns
differently then you'd yeah and there
was a point in time where I looked at it
I there was a point in time where I
looked at it probably the same way you
did right I had about as an organic
progression to firearm ownership as one
can have
I was against guns I didn't like him but
I went to the range one time and I shot
a gun and that changed for me and so now
I can see I can see of a myriad of
reasons for why someone would own a
firearm
whether it be recreation sports
collecting so forth and so on so when I
see that those number of guns up there
my mind doesn't automatically go - oh my
god that's horrible that's bad okay I
totally hear what you're saying I guess
what I'm saying to you is what you're
trying to do is say that progressives
liberals whatever want to ban guns no
one's saying ban your gun we're saying
regulate them so people with mental
illness have background checks a variety
of things about certain types of guns no
one is saying you can't have a gun and I
know the NRA
always wants to say people are saying
bad guys but they're not they're simply
saying for my safety and the protection
of children and other public people you
should we should have regulations like
background checks on every single gun
now how would you enforce that okay if
we're gonna suggest a solution at least
have something that's enforceable right
it is enforceable we do this for gun
shows do them for regular that
discussions of bills the NRA fight sent
to me
the to me Manchin bill support that bill
would you support that bill that's my
question and that's the that's it I was
in force when did I lose control of this
whole show
okay but more of this ongoing NRA to
begin you could debate it for all
[Applause]